the 2016
presidential election or as it's more
commonly known the electoral equivalent
of seeing someone puking so you start
puking and then someone else is puking
and pretty soon everyone is puking 2016.
the first presidential debate is
tomorrow night more than a hundred
million people
could be watching two candidates whose
campaigns have been defined less by
questions about their policies
than their ethics every day is another
drip drip drip of scandal for hillary
clinton
another clinton scandal too many
scandals have followed her
and bill clinton over the years what
about the trump scandals another trump
campaign
scandal another booming scandal of the
day with him but there are so many it's
hard to keep track
listen we have had scandals during
campaigns in the past from barack
obama's financial dealings with tony
rezko
to george w bush's air national guard
service to the revelation that dwight d
eisenhower's middle initial stood for
deez nuts but
but this campaign this complaint the
scandals have been
so pronounced polls show that less than
half the electorate sees either
candidate as honest or trustworthy and
you may not like
either candidate for good reasons but if
you are still somehow torn about which
one to vote for
and are factoring their scandals into
your decision we thought
it might help to spend tonight walking
you through them so let's start
with hillary clinton the woman who if
she loses will sit there motionless not
speaking until she eventually dies
and i do know that even talking about
her scandals will irritate some of you
given that her opponent
is an unambiguously racist scarecrow
stuffed with scrunched up copies of jugs
magazine
and that's fair that is a fair point but
not being as bad as donald trump is a
low bar to clear and if you focus
on nothing but him you fail to vet a
woman who might be president
and if you believe the internet she's
guilty of everything
just click around and you can find such
masterworks as hillary clinton
uh hillary ordered the murder of the
children of waco
hillary the butcher of benghazi and my
personal favorite
is hillary clinton satan hillary i am
the devil
and you know that's in quotes on the
internet so she must have said it
although although to be fair she could
have been referring to her time as the
new jersey devil's mascot
now now many of hillary's most famous
scandals
have been heavily litigated in the past
for instance uh whitewater
now more than six years of
investigations by three different
prosecutors and multiple congressional
committees
failed to find sufficient evidence of
wrongdoing then there was
benghazi now eight congressional
investigations
broadly concluded the state department
could have done more to increase
security at the embassy
but non-found evidence of wrongdoing by
clinton and then
there is the problematic issue of the
swiss file transfer and while yes
investigators found hillary was in
zurich at the time of the transfer and
documents show
she was aware the transfer took place
and yes the clintons did have something
to gain financially from it the fact is
the swiss file transfer is something i
just made up right now
but the very fact that for a second you
kind of remembered it
says something about the tone of
coverage surrounding clinton
but many but many rational people
are still worried about two particular
scandals it turns out
nearly half of all americans are very
concerned about both her emails
and the clinton foundation so let's
start with the emails which you may
remember from their starring role at the
republican national convention
she put our nation's security
at extremely high risk with her careless
use of a private email server hillary
clinton cared more about protecting her
own secrets
that she cared about protecting
america's secrets
she jeopardized the american people our
national security
with her secret email server she lied
okay hillary's emails were basically the
unofficial theme
of the rnc right alongside how loud can
giuliani scream
and happy days residuals can't buy you
attention
but but while some of hillary's
opponents feel her email scandal should
put her in prison
at least at the beginning she claimed
there was nothing to see
everything i did was permitted there was
no law
there was no regulation there was
nothing that did not
give me the full authority to decide how
i was going to communicate
and people across the government knew
that i used one device
maybe it was because i am not the most
technically
capable person and wanted to make it as
easy as possible
and now i think it's kind of fun people
get a real-time behind-the-scenes look
at you know what i was emailing about
and what i was communicating about
now that is a bad answer for a number of
reasons
first she says everything i did was
permitted which isn't remotely true
the use of a private email server would
have required prior approval and she
never asked for it
then she blames not being technically
capable which is a fine excuse for your
dad
when he accidentally text you the letter
q 10 times
but it's pretty shitty coming from a
secretary of state
and then she caps it off by saying the
whole thing is kind of fun
which it definitely isn't unless every
single one of her emails was just
a jpeg of a dog dressed as dracula in
which case
yeah you know what that is kind of fun
so there have been exaggerations
on both sides and while she since
acknowledged that her use of the server
was a mistake
the idea persists that it was a good
deal more
so let's walk through what we actually
know hillary clinton this started due to
a simple
tech issue because when she took office
in 2009
department issued blackberries couldn't
access two different email accounts
clinton said today it was more
convenient for her to carry one
device instead of separate devices for
work and personal emails
looking back it would have been better
for me to use two separate phones
and two email accounts i thought using
one device would be simpler
and obviously it hasn't worked out that
way
yeah no so this
whole situation could potentially have
been avoided if she just had the ability
to carry
two blackberries meaning it's the only
time the best advice a politician could
have received
was cargo shorts so
if she wanted one phone she had a few
options first use a state.gov email
address for all her emails
meaning her personal emails would reside
on government servers potentially
making them more accessible to request
for public records so instead
hillary sent everything through a
non-government address
it's a practice that's legal but highly
discouraged
although she is by no means the only one
who has done that others include colin
powell
john kerry chris christie jeb bush rick
perry scott walker martin o'malley greg
abbott bobby jindal
sarah palin ashton carter and karl rove
and epa administrator lisa jackson
had a different work around using a
second government email under the alias
richard windsor
which turned out to be a mashup of her
dog's name and her family's hometown
so she was basically doing government
business under her porn name
which cannot catch on because nobody
wants to be writing to housing and urban
development secretary julian castro at
bud.thunderjunk at hud dot bone
that can't happen but hillary went
much further than just having a private
email she had her own private server
and it wasn't just any old server to
put an email server at your house is not
a it's a complicated thing
yeah but it was already there it had
been there for years it is the
system that my husband's uh personal
office
used when he got out of the white house
and so it was sitting there in the
basement
wait wait you used a server that bill
clinton had been using
which was in your basement i hate to
tell you this
but you just stored government records
on a machine that bill called
the pawn master 5000
i love that machine old
faithful now the private server wasn't
the only way hillary communicated there
was a separate official government
system for classified information
unfortunately
some email sent to hillary did contain
pieces of information that were
classified in nature
the fbi found 113 such emails though
in fairness only three of them had
classification markers
and were not in the header of the email
as they should have been and while the
fbi found clinton and her staff to be
extremely careless
they said they couldn't find a case that
would support bringing criminal charges
so it's not good but it's not as bad as
it looks
which is never a satisfying thing to
hear
or indeed read above the buffet at a
golden corral
so so that is basically
the emails let's now move on to the
clinton foundation
six months ago it was known as the
top-rated global foundation that has
among other things helped millions
around the world
access lower-cost hiv treatment but it
has now become possibly the only charity
that inspires more visceral
anger than this one eight seven seven
seven
shut up shut up what is this charity
your kids you can't drive
what money laundering scheme are you
operating
look the point is the point is
the controversy with the clinton
foundation is not so much what they did
with their money
it's the possible conflict of interest
in taking donations from individuals and
foreign governments with business before
the state department
and to be fair in 2008 the foundation
tried to head this
off by promising the obama
administration they'd not only disclose
all donations
but also get advance approval for any
coming from
certain foreign governments which they
did but
a few slipped through there's one
involving algeria donating half a
million dollars although there's
no proof that state department policy
was swayed as a result more concerning
is one involving russia which does sound
bad
reports out overnight say the state
department with clinton at the helm
approved the sale of one of america's
largest uranium mines to russia at the
same time
a foundation controlled by the mines
chairman was making donations to the
clinton foundation we are talking about
some big money here
four separate donations totaling 2.35
million dollars and these reports say
that the donations were not publicly
disclosed
holy there are so many not good
words in that one sound bite
russia uranium controlled big money and
not disclosed
it could only be worse if it also
contained the words orifice shard
butt chug and cosby now now brace
yourself
because this gets pretty dense basically
the canadian chairman of the mining
company that was eventually sold to
russia had also given money to the
clinton foundation but instead of doing
it directly
he gave it through this canadian
affiliate which didn't disclose his name
because it didn't have to because the
affiliate wasn't actually included
in that agreement the clinton foundation
signed with the obama administration so
neither the law nor the agreement were
technically violated
though the spirit of the agreement
definitely was so again this
looks bad especially given that the
state department did sign off
on the sale of that uranium mile to
russia but
not only was hillary not involved in
that decision
but eight other federal agencies plus
the nuclear regulatory commission
also had to sign off which they did so
this donation was legal
but very annoyingly handled and any
suggestion of
pay for play fails to account for the
separate actions of nine unrelated
government agencies basically it's
complicated
and like the movie it's complicated it
probably would have been best for
everyone
if it had never happened but no one
broke the law and look
we've spent several frustrating weeks
trawling through
all the innuendo and exaggeration
surrounding her email and foundation
scandals and the worst thing you can say
is
they both look bad but the harder you
look
the less you actually find there's not
nothing there
what is there is irritating rather than
grossly nefarious and this
is where it's instructive to compare her
to her opponent
donald trump america's wealthiest
hemorrhoid
because if you are struggling with the
idea of voting for hillary because of
all this you need to take a long
hard look at trump if you're irritated
by her lying that is understandable
but he is quantifiably worse politifact
checked around the same number of
statements from both of them over the
years and found around 13
of hillary's statements to be flatly
false but for trump
that figure was a whopping 53
presumably it's only that low because
the rest of the time you were saying
things
like this if ivanka weren't my daughter
perhaps i'd be dating her you know
it's so weird yeah that's probably true
and the fact is probably true is what
makes it so horrifying
and if you're thinking okay hillary may
not lie as much as trump but she needs
to be more transparent
that's fair enough but bear in mind
we know almost nothing about trump's
finances and that is not good
he's the first major party nominee since
1980 not to release his tax returns and
his justification
is pathetic i will absolutely give my
return but i'm being audited now
for two or three years so i can't do it
until the audit is finished
but yes you can the irs has explicitly
said
you don't need to wait for a completed
audit to release them you're just saying
two completely unrelated things or i'd
love to pick you up from the airport but
i can't
because a blue whale's tongue weighs as
much as an elephant
what the are you talking about
those two things
have nothing to do with each other and
and on top of trump's personal tax
records there are unanswered questions
about his business dealings
as many experts have pointed out his
investments debts
and business ties span the globe and
could present
unprecedented ethical challenges for a
president
now traditionally presidential
candidates in that kind of situation
promise to put their financial holdings
into a blind
trust where an independent trustee is
given control
over their investments but when trump
was asked if he would do that as well
he seemed not to know what it meant are
you planning on putting your assets in a
blind trust should you become president
i have ivanka and eric and don sitting
there
run the company kids have a good time
i'm going to do it for america
so i would i would be willing to do it
so you'll put your assets in a blind
trust
i would put it in a blind shot well i
don't know if it's a blind trust of
ivanka don and eric run it but
is that a blind trust i don't know no
that is
not a blind trust it's the opposite of
one
almost anything else you could have said
would have been closer to a blind trust
oh i'm going to put my assets in an
upside down dog house filled with
pudding
is that a blind trust no that's
ridiculous but you're actually closer
than you were before
and even more alarmingly when george
stephanopoulos talked to donald trump jr
he didn't seem to understand what a
blind trust was either
it's not a blind trust if you and your
siblings are still running we're not
going to be involved in government
we wouldn't even know the you're running
the company
and he's president so any foreign but
he's not making
any decisions as it relates to the
company but a blind trust
it's not a blind trust if it's being run
by his children it is because he'll have
nothing to do with it george he's still
going to know what the businesses are
and where they are
we will not understand because we're not
going to discuss those things it doesn't
matter
trust me wait trust
you the only reasonable thing to trust
you
on is which hair products can best make
someone look like a 1980s serial killer
that's it and look if the financial
actions
of the clinton foundation annoy you let
me introduce you to the trump foundation
and i'm not talking about the estimated
12 pounds of foundation that trump wears
on his face
i'm talking about his charitable
organization
the washington post has been
investigating and has found among other
things that trump has not personally
given it any money
since 2008 and just this week this story
broke
donald trump is facing questions tonight
about his
charitable foundation after a report
today in the washington post
the foundation spent more than a quarter
of a million dollars of donated money
to settle lawsuits against trump
businesses
yes trump reportedly used his
foundation's money which had been
donated by people for charitable
purposes
as a tool to make some legal disputes go
away are on the spectrum
of shittiest things you can do that is
right up there with catfishing a baby
owl
he waited all night for you and he's
nocturnal
so that's his day gone uh and trump
also allegedly used foundation money to
purchase ridiculous items for himself
in another instance trump's foundation
paid ten thousand dollars at a charity
auction
in 2014 for a portrait painted of trump
it was the second time trump used
foundation funds
for a portrait of him okay okay
okay wait wait wait wait just for a
start what is he doing with his face
in that photo that is not a smile that's
waking up in the middle of a colonoscopy
and also on top of that how did that
portrait
cost ten thousand dollars it looks like
someone xeroxed a black and white
picture of trump and then painted over
it with condiments from burger king
now now what trump did there would
technically be legal as long as
the portrait itself was put to some
charitable purpose
well univision found it and it wasn't
exactly in an orphanage
this is the painting that donald trump
purchased with funds donated to the
charitable foundation that carries his
last name
this morning univision got the scoop
that the artwork remained hanging
inside the restaurant champions bar and
grill inside the doral hotel and golf
course a property owned by donald trump
now in trump's defense that portrait is
the perfect pairing for his restaurant
signature dishes
which are apparently according to yelp
reviewers watery tomato chunks with no
flavor
and craft beer brands misspelled on the
menu
and it is not just portraits trump also
wants to use foundation funds to buy a
signed tim tebow helmet
a steal at twelve thousand dollars for
something that once contained the head
of america's worst quarterback
he also used funds to make an illegal
political donation to support florida a
g
pam bondi around the time that she was
considering investigating his not a
university university
so it seems the trump foundation may
exist primarily to benefit trump himself
in which case they should really change
the name to something more appropriate
like
the national association for the
advancement of donald trump
or the naadt for short and the thing is
we have barely scratched the surface of
his scandals there is everything
from the ongoing lawsuits against that
university
to the alleged use of undocumented
workers when building trump tower
to the fact he received an illegal 3.5
million
loan from his father in the form of a
purchase of chips
from one of trump's casinos and that
loan could not have been shadier
if it was given in baggies of cocaine or
the bones of endangered species
look the point is this campaign has been
dominated by scandals but it is
dangerous to think that there is an
equal number on both sides
and you can be irritated by some of
hillary's that is
understandable but you should then be
outraged by trumps think of it like this
ethical failings in a politician are
like
raisins in a cookie they shouldn't be
there they disgust people
but most politicians have at least a few
raisins and hillary
is a cookie like this one she she
arguably has more raisins than average
there's probably
10 of those little in there but
we all need to remember that when it
comes to donald trump
this is the amount of raisins that he
represents
the man is a raisin monsoon
he is ethically compromised to an almost
unprecedented degree so if you don't
like raisins
i get it they're disgusting but
unfortunately this november
you're gonna have to swallow 10 or we're
all gonna be eating this for years